these children shelter from the Sun in
the Mexican city of Nuevo Laredo near
the border with the United States
temperatures have reached 43 degrees
Celsius in recent days Mariana Padilla
and her infant daughter are among those
waiting in the blistering heat to claim
asylum in the U.S they've traveled more
than three and a half thousand
kilometers from Colombia
the sun rises at seven in the morning
and it starts burning hard since we
sleep on cardboard on the ground we need
to get up early and put our baby in her
stroller to take her out we look for
places with little dirt and shade in the
afternoon we take her out when the sun
comes down
hundreds of Asylum Seekers are being
forced to take shelter under makeshift
tents in camps and nearby parks some say
authorities are making an already
difficult situation unbearable
we've tried to ensure the high
temperatures because we need to be here
we cannot leave we do it as a sacrifice
for our children and for ourselves but
we don't get any answers here we used to
have water other benefits which have
been gradually taken away we had
electricity but they took away power
water and staff from Doctors Without
Borders
many of the Asylum Seekers waiting for
permission to enter the U.S are from
Venezuela they've endured a long and
dangerous journey to get here they say
the sweltering heat is another challenge
they must now overcome
we need to buy ice constantly they bring
a certain amount of ice and water but
due to the amount of people it runs out
quickly most of the day we feel low in
energy and dehydrated
the heat wave is expected to last at
least another two weeks but people here
say they'll wait as long as it takes
hoping their chances of a better life
will improve Victoria gate and B Al
Jazeera